fabriquer un journal éviter l'effet que
muse et mener une enquête
voilà les thématiques abordées tout
l'après-midi un séminaire pour favoriser
le dialogue entre acteurs de
l'information et habitants des quartiers
prioritaires
j'ai un moment où vous dites besoin est
important le lien était dégradée parce
que ça ne valorise pas les habitants que
de toujours voir au journal télévision
télévisée des barres d'immeubles des
voitures qui brûlent des poubelles qui
brûlent des violences urbaines
donc il fallait vraiment que les
habitants des quartiers les
professionnels soit face aux
journalistes et qu'ils se parlent
doivent être conscients qu'ils sont
porteurs d'un message qui peut
dévastateur ou très bénéfique
et si on ne fait pas attention mais on
peut catapulter une commune par exemple
quand la mienne
quinze ans en arrière retrouver une
confiance mutuelle par en échange
sincère de 150 élus policiers éducateurs
et travailleurs sociaux ont participé à
cette conférence animée par des
journalistes de france télévisions pour
le rédacteur en chef du magazine
enquêtes de france deux caches
investigations plus d'événements de ce
type devraient avoir lieu à une très
grande défiance vis-à-vis du travail des
journalistes et vis-à-vis de
l'information en général je crois que
voilà le seul moyen de sortir cette
défiance et devenir de s'expliquer
l'éducation à l'image
l'éducation à l'info doit faire partie
de ce qu'on apprend de ce qu'on apprend
dans l'est dans les écoles c'est
important parce que ça fait partie de la
vie ce partenariat entre france
télévisions et la préfecture des
yvelines a été mis en place en début
d'année 2010 est il a permis de réaliser
différentes actions d'éducation aux
médias